also know that we recently launched our
better than nothing beta program in the
northern us
and southern canada so i'll be sure to
talk all about that
a little bit later in the webcast we're
currently at t minus nine and a half
minutes till launch and all systems are
go for an on-time liftoff this evening
good evening my name is shiva bharathaj
and i'm a space operations engineer here
at spacex
on your screen is a live view of falcon
9 that's our two-stage liquid fueled
vehicle
now falcon 9 is 70 meters tall which is
greater than the wingspan of a 747
aircraft
as kate had mentioned previously we are
flying today's booster for the seventh
time
that's a first for falcon 9. this rocket
previously flew on the telstar 18
vantage mission
the iridium 7 mission as well as 4
starlink missions
now falcon 9 was designed for 10 or more
flights with minimal refurbishment in
between each flight and today's flight
will get us
closer to that goal the bottom two
thirds of the vehicle is what we refer
to as
the first stage you can actually tell
that tell it from the submarkings left
over from its previous
six flights now the first stage's job is
to accelerate the vehicle
through the earth's atmosphere into
space with the help of nine merlin
engines
that it has at the base of the rocket we
will be attempting to recover this first
stage
uh for the seventh time on our drone
ship named of course i still love you
pictured on your screen
about 630 or so kilometers down range
now on top of the first stage is our
black carbon fiber inner stage
and on top of that is falcon 9's second
stage it has a single merlin vacuum
or m-vac engine and once the first and
second stages
separate about two and a half minutes
into the mission that merlin vacuum
engine will ignite
and carry the 60 starling satellites
into an elliptical orbit around planet
earth
now falcon 9 has been loading propellant
since about t minus 35 minutes
we use a rocket grade kerosene or rocket
propellant 1 rp1
as our fuel and super chilled liquid
oxygen
or lox as our oxidizer to power the
falcon 9.
now propellants are nearly fully loaded
on both
the first and second stages where we'll
be continuing
to top up the liquid oxygen
until the final minutes of the countdown
now the very top
of the rocket is our nose cone structure
that's what we call the satellite
fairing that's where the stack of those
60 starling satellites is safely housed
the fairing's job is to protect those
satellites from aerothermal heating
aerodynamic loads and contamination
during ascent
and once we reach the vacuum of space
we'll actually jettison them back
as the second stage will continue on its
journey to orbit
we are flying a flight proven fairing
today it'll be the second flight
for one of the halves and the third
flight for the other
and our recovery vessels mischief and go
searcher will be attempting to recover
those fairing halves today by scooping
them out of the water
now a quick update on the weather uh
we've been tracking
uh some minor cumulus clouds and
actually wind in the area but overall we
are at an 80
chance of go so keeping an eye on those
winds but other than that
vehicle satellites weather and the range
all looking good for an on time liftoff
just a few minutes from now
as many of you know starlink is a
constellation of satellites that can
provide
high-speed low-latency internet all over
the globe
particularly in remote or rural areas
where connectivity is limited
or completely unavailable to date
starlink space
spacex has launched nearly 900 starlink
satellites to orbit
less than a month ago we rolled out our
better than nothing beta service to the
northern u.s
and just last week we rolled out service
to parts of southern canada
during our first public beta users can
expect to see data speeds vary from 50
megabits per second to 150 megabits per
second
and latency vary from 20 milliseconds to
40 milliseconds
there will also be brief periods of no
connectivity at all
as we launch more satellites install
more ground stations
and improve our networking software data
speed
latency and uptime will all improve
dramatically
for latency we expect to achieve 16 to
19 milliseconds by summer 2021
right now our beta program is invitation
only and it is based entirely on your
location
within the northern us and southern
canada we are focused on rural and
remote areas
where there is no easy access to fiber
or cable
now on your screen there you see an
example of one of our service areas or
what we call
a cell this particular cell is in an
area of
minnesota near the town of dole hey
hitter dole folks
so based on this example if you lived in
hitter doll
hawley winnipeg junction or the nearby
area
we could probably service you but if for
example you lived in lake park
you'd be just outside of our current
coverage area
now we have cells like this all over the
northern us
and canada within the 45 to 53 degree
latitudes
and with every launch of starling
satellites we enable our team to serve
more and more of these cells
if you're hoping to receive an invite
all you need is a bit of patience
at our current pace we expect to expand
our beta in a notable way
very early next year in the late january
february time frame
if that sounds interesting to you head
over to starlink.com and sign up
we're just over four minutes away from
liftoff falcon 9 is now moving into the
final stages of countdown
now at this point the first and second
stages are
fully loaded with rp1 and nearly fully
loaded
with liquid oxygen there's almost a
million pounds of both of those
propellants
on the vehicle super chilled liquid
oxygen which i mentioned earlier
is our propellant oxidizer is actually
what's creating that white
cloud that you see coming off of falcon
9's inner stage
that's what happens when that cold
liquid oxygen comes into contact
with the moist florida air and causes
water vapor to condense
into clouds we'll be continuing to top
up the liquid oxygen
on both the first and second stage we'll
expect to hear a call out here for
lox load closeout on the first stage at
about t minus three minutes
and then about a minute after that t
minus two minutes we'll hear a similar
call out
for the second stage and you can really
get a sense of
the wind right on the pad from those
streams
from the liquid oxygen venting
off the stage
pogo bleed verification
now coming up at about uh again we'll
have
at t minus two minutes lox load closeout
on the second stage
and then uh at t minus 60 seconds falcon
9 will transition into startup
that means that the rockets internal
flight computers have taken over the
launch countdown
and they'll continue to have control of
the vehicle
through the rest of the mission at this
point the starlik
payload also continues to look healthy
falcon 9 team not tracking any issues
on the vehicle
the big watch item right now is the
winds they were projected to to dip
right around the launch window again
about two minutes away from now keeping
an eye on those making sure that we
don't violate
any lunch commit criteria
wide shot there a few locks close out
wide shot there of the pad and the call
from the prop team that stage two locks
loading is complete
but that propellants are fully loaded on
falcon 9.
coming up here we will have a pretty
large white cloud of venting coming from
the transporter erector
that's the truss structure next to
falcon 9
and it provides power cooling
and propellants as well as communication
to falcon 9 until liftoff
so coming up transition to startup
on falcon 9.
falcon 9's and start
so again that means from here falcon 9
will begin to pressurize
those tanks the first stage and second
stage stink
tanks with our pressure for flight lb's
go for launch
great news from the launch director
giving
their go for flight
so with that just 30 seconds to go
vehicle looking healthy looks like we
may have just squeaked in
startling satellites also continuing to
look healthy
why don't we listen in and watch
terminal count
2 minus 15 seconds falcon 9 is
configured for flight
10 9 8 seven
six five four three
two one zero
ignitions
vehicles pitching down range
m1d chamber pressures
40 seconds into flight falcon 9
successfully lifting off from pad 40 at
cape canaveral air force stations
nominal
carrying those 60 starling satellites
into orbit this particular booster
letting up the florida coast for a
seventh time
now we just began throttling down those
merlin 1d
engines for maximum dynamic pressure or
max q
that's the point when the stresses on
the vehicle
are the highest from the combination of
the vehicle speed
and the density of the atmosphere
execute and now that we're through the
point of maximum dynamic pressure the
loads on the vehicle the structural
loads are going to drop off as the
density of the atmosphere continues to
decrease
and falcon 9 continuing to speed up
we're about a minute away from three
events
first of those is main engine cutoff or
miko that's where we'll shut off those
nine
merlin 1d engines you can actually see
the plume expanding from them
on your on your camera you shut those
down
engine chills started in preparation for
stage separation
that's where the first and second stages
will separate from each other for stage
continuing on a parabolic arc to make
its way back to the drone ship
while the second stage continues on to
the third event
second engine start number one we
actually just heard the call out there
for uh mvac chill in beginning
so during that third event second engine
start one we'll ignite the merlin vacuum
engine that'll propel
the second stage along with the
startling satellites into an elliptical
orbit
and we chill in those turbo pumps with
liquid oxygen just to get them
ready for ignition
and miko stage separation confirmed
left hand side of your screen
first stage separating second stage
ignition
love that green glow from the tteb
ignition
both vehicles back on their way coming
up shortly we'll expect to see fairing
deployment off of the second stage look
for that on the right hand side of your
screen
bearing separation confirmed
beautiful shot there of those starling
satellites finally getting to see space
directly we now that we're outside
of the atmosphere the we don't need
those fairing halves anymore so
we'll adjust them back to earth to
recover them as a reminder we do have
our recovery ships
mischief and go searcher waiting at the
atlantic
to scoop up both of those fairing halves
on the left hand side of your screen
there we saw the very last remnants of
night lights visible off the florida
coast
as a pretty awesome sight there as
falcon 9 lifted off
now there we can see second stage with a
healthy glow there on the mvac
engine as second stage heads towards its
targeted drop off orbit
the first stage will execute two burns
in order to make its way
back to earth now if you happen to have
followed along with our most recent
launch on this past
saturday where we launched out of
vandenberg air force base
we performed three maneuvers in that
instance because we were returning to
launch site where we were landing the
first stage back on land
tonight we are landing on the drone ship
as shiva said before
of course i still love you so we only
need to perform two maneuvers
because we are continuing the arc
trajectory
of the first stage so that first burn
is the entry burn and we will reignite
three of the nine m1d engines at the
base of the first stage
and this will help to slow that stage
down as it re-enters the upper part of
the earth's atmosphere
and then the second burn is the landing
burn this is a single engine burn
that brings the vehicle speed down
rapidly in order to make a soft layer it
goes on a nominal tractor
so we heard there that the vehicle's on
nominal trajectory that's
good good news there
at this point in time the first stage
has reached apogee
and is now starting its trip back down
to the ocean
our drone ship is parked a couple
hundred miles off the coast of
florida in the atlantic ocean
it is as you saw a nighttime launch and
unfortunately
we can't really see anything so we're we
don't have very good
first stage footage to show you at this
point in time but we will bring that
back in
once we get some landing uh burn action
and reentry burn action checking in on
second stage everything continues to
look good
the 60 starlink satellites that are on
board today
are joining the constellation of nearly
900 that we've already placed on
orbit these satellites are designed
to provide high-speed low-latency
internet
to folks like us here on earth
and this is especially helpful to for
places where
good internet is hard to access
first stage is continuing to coast and
it uses
nothing but grid fins for that steering
as well as
occasional nitrogen gas bursts for
attitude control
stage 1 fts is saved so on your left
hand side
of the screen yes we will see the entry
burn beginning
and entry burn has begun and this will
last for
about another 20 seconds
again this is the first of two maneuvers
that the first stage will perform
tonight
shut down and shut down of first stage
entry burn
so that's two burns used to follow a
nominal trajectory that burn was
designed to
slow the booster down significantly as
it reenters the upper part
of the upper parts of the earth's
atmosphere
the next maneuver will be the landing
burn and it is the final one
where we reignite just one single merlin
engine
to make a soft landing on top of the
drone ship
we mentioned earlier this is the seventh
return sonic uh we just heard that the
booster is now transonic
as it is re-entering the earth's
atmosphere
as i was saying this is the seventh
successful launch for
this booster and that will make this the
seventh
recovery attempt
everything's continuing to look good
there on the second stage
and back engine has begun to throttle
down landing burns
there we heard the callout that landing
burn has begun so we should see that
coming to the screen here just
momentarily stage two fts is safe
stage one landing leg deploy landing
legs have deployed
here it comes
all right and for the seventh time
this falcon has landed
this marks our 61st successful recovery
of a falcon 9 first stage and we have
chico and as the smoke clears
we can get a good view there and we just
heard the callout that we had seco one
or
second engine cut off one so at this
point in time
and there we had heard the call out that
we have good orbit for that second stage
so now that stage two is uh it's going
to coast in this orbit for
a few minutes during this time it will
start to spin along its central axis
giving the starlink satellites the
momentum that they need to space
themselves out
over time as they deploy so we're going
to take a quick break here
but we will be returning at t plus 14
minutes so stick around
expect the glass of signal cape
acquisition of signal new finland
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
so
[Music]
this
[Music]
[Music]
expected loss of signal bermuda
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to our webcast for our
starlink launch today now if you're just
joining us we had a successful liftoff
at 9
13 p.m eastern time successfully
recovered
our first stage for the seventh time
that's the first time for us
and you're currently looking at a live
view of the second stage
in a nominal orbit around planet earth
we're coming up on deployment of the
starlink satellites
you can see the stack of those on your
screen in just about 10 seconds
now over the course of the break we
began spinning the second stage along
its central axis
that's to give those starling satellites
a little bit of momentum
upon separation
looks like we have a visual there
and call out of confirmation of starlink
deployment
so those 60 star-like satellites gently
floating away
from the second stage and uh because of
the spin
on the second stage they'll start to
space themselves out
soon they'll deploy a solar array that
they have on board
and then over the next few days and
weeks they'll distance themselves out
further
using an onboard ion thruster to make
their way to an operational orbit about
kilometers above the earth's surface
so overall very exciting day for us at
spacex first time we have flown
a booster for the seventh time first
time we have landed a booster
for the seventh time and of course
always lovely to see
our deploy payload deployment successful
on the mission
and that will bring our webcast to a
close this evening
thank you to the range and faa for
supporting today's mission
and of course thank you to all of our
viewers as well as
those in the us and canada who have
ordered starlink under
our public beta program if you haven't
signed up yet and are interested in
being part of our beta program
head over to starlink.com and sign up
thanks for joining us and have a great
evening